no you haven't you I mean you know we
see you on your television but really
you are in America now you are making
films proper films I've been off making
some films hopefully I might stay in
some of them and they at some point we
don't look you at the rock I mean you're
in a film with the rock I did a film
with the rock yes he's the best man I've
ever met
he's what well second-best maybe now
he's amazing and he's the kindest guy he
has this gym that he travels with which
I got to go into which I felt very
honored to be invited into the iron
paradise so but it's cool yeah it's his
traveling gym and one day on set he was
like do you work out and I was like yep
yep the gym and I went round and these
machines are enormous he had taken all
of the weights off all of the machines
just the bars in the corner and got onto
an exercise bike and popped in an audio
book like a chain round is crunching all
of this iron that listen to rap music
and I'm over there like want to call the
Midwife
[Applause]
[Music]
you